we are really getting very close to the
2022 midterm elections and what I want
to do is take a look at some of the most
important races potentially what we
might call Bellwether races also
potentially difference making races as
far as the U.S Senate is concerned see
where things are and talk about where we
go from here now a little bit later on
in the program many of you dozens and
dozens of you emailing me over the
weekend about so many of the incredible
debates that took place over this
weekend Marjorie Taylor green debating
her opponent Marcus flowers Herschel
Walker debating Rafael Warnock Ron
Johnson debating Mandela Barnes Kerry
Lake
in a very strange CNN interview about
whether or not she would accept the
results we're going to look at all of
that but to first set the stage let's
take a look at some of what I consider
to be the most important races either
because
they could be the Difference Maker in
who controls the senate or because they
have some other particular importance
like the Pennsylvania gubernatorial
election now
I know people are going to email and say
but David sir you missed this race or
you missed that race and it's so
important I can't look at every race I'm
also not looking at any Congressional
races in this segment because it's it's
very unlikely that the Congressional
balance will depend on one seat and so
there's just so many congressional races
to look at that I'm not doing that right
now but let's just start going down the
list and see where these races stand
first and foremost Pennsylvania Governor
Pennsylvania Governor matters so much
because when you look at swing States
for a presidential election and then you
look at which of the Swing States could
be the sole Difference Maker and who
becomes the next president of the United
States Pennsylvania is at or near the
top of that list and Doug mastriano the
Republican candidate in Pennsylvania is
openly running
on a big lie campaign platform if given
the opportunity if Doug mastriano is the
governor of Pennsylvania in 2024 he gets
to choose the secretary of state which
oversees the election and he will pick
someone who would be willing to just
straight up try to steal Pennsylvania's
electoral votes if a Democrat wins and
they don't like it they will try to
steal it for the Republican this is an
extraordinarily important race the good
news here
is that Josh Shapiro the Democratic
candidate is winning by an average of 10
points that is a significant lead I'm
not going to say this after every one of
these races but assume nothing everyone
must vote this is just a reflection of
where the polling today is best based on
the best data we have there's still time
things can depart from the polling but
this one so far is looking pretty good
Josh Shapiro there's very little to say
about Josh Shapiro because he's so
uncontroversial some might say he's milk
toast others will say he's just a
completely normal person who isn't going
to try to steal any elections this one
is looking good
and we really have to hope that Josh
Shapiro does win also in Pennsylvania is
the Senate race the senate race is
television Dr Mehmet Oz against the
lieutenant governor John fetterman Oz is
the Republican fetterman is the Democrat
John fetterman had a stroke months ago
there is now a big campaign in which
Oz's campaign is participating even if
Oz himself is less overtly participating
in it to basically say because of the
stroke fetterman can't be a senator we
already addressed that last week in
quite a bit of detail the good news here
is that fetterman's winning the bad news
here is that fetterman isn't winning by
that much right now it's about a three
and a half Point margin on average for
fetterman in recent polling Pennsylvania
is maybe the most important state in the
midterms both because of it's the senate
race and it's the gubernatorial our
friends in Pennsylvania
I hope every single one of you is
planning to vote
Florida Florida has a very interesting
Senate race and again the Senate may
come down to just one seat so every one
of these big Senate races is important
incumbent Republican Marco Rubio kind of
a pathetic character there's just
something about him that's very pathetic
key in a bad way not in the old
philosophical sense he is facing a
challenge from congresswoman Val demings
on the Democratic side
it's not looking great for Val demings
but this is still potentially winnable
Rubio is up by somewhere between four
and five points we will be carrying the
debate between Rubio and demings
you know it might have been rescheduled
so it might be tomorrow it might be
later on in the month anyway when it
happens if it does I will carry it
Florida voters you've got an important
race there as well also in Florida is
the gubernatorial race and again when we
think about I mean listen think about
Florida Florida
could be the Difference Maker and who
becomes president in 2024 but moreover
the guy who wants to be re-elected as
Governor Ron DeSantis may end up being
the Republican Presidential nominee in
2024 so this one is doubly important and
as I've said before it's not looking
good for Charlie Chris the Democratic
Challenger Ron DeSantis has a
comfortable lead of just under eight
points that will be difficult to
overcome but listen all of our Florida
viewers should be voting regardless
because of that Senate race so when
you're there you vote for governor we
try to get Ron DeSantis out even though
it is an uphill battle then we go to
North Carolina this one has not gotten
that much attention but it really should
because it's so close Sherry Beasley is
the Democratic nominee
um Ted bud is the Republican nominee
it's almost a tie okay if you look at
the only polling from the last
month okay it's a tie and the Republican
plus one and on average including
earlier polling Real Clear Politics has
this as a one and a half point lead for
Ted Budd let's not sleep on North
Carolina and I know there's the
Assumption in North Carolina the
undecideds are going to turn out for the
Republican and all the different things
what what better thing do we have to do
than vote okay let's just let's vote and
let's see where we get but that's a race
not getting as much attention and it
really should North Carolina you can
vote for Sherry Beasley then we go to
Wisconsin Wisconsin
I'll be honest
I don't really know
exactly where this race is going right
now because there was an absolutely
humiliating debate over the weekend
where the incumbent Republican Senator
Ron Johnson was booed
he was openly laughed at and he bombed
in his debate against Challenger Mandela
Barnes who by the way Mandela Barnes has
been a guest on this program you can go
check out in the archives on YouTube or
on our website my interview with Mandela
Barnes super smart guy
um Barnes crushed the debate so all of
the polling I have is at least eight
days old it has Johnson leading by just
under three points even if that's the
case today that Johnson is leading by
about three points this one is possible
and the disastrous debate performance
for Johnson over the weekend may hurt
him further so this is a very important
race this is a possible seat that can be
taken from Republicans then of course we
have the State of Arizona two important
races there we covered the Arizona
Senate debate that's incumbent Democrat
Mark Kelly challenged by Maga trumpist
Blake Masters Blake Masters is horrible
and dishonest and unethical and just
vile a gross gross guy he uh scrubbed
all of the violently anti abortion stuff
from his website after the primary but
now is kind of trying to explain it away
and he can't he is a big lie proponent
although he downplayed that during the
debate a week and a half ago with Mark
Kelly right now the good news is Kelly
is up four and a half
the bad news is Kelly should be up 40.
but Kelly was not particularly good in
the debate Kelly is not like an electric
exciting guy
um so if you vote in Arizona not only do
you have this Senate race but you also
have maybe even more disturbingly the
Arizona gubernatorial race in Arizona
the incumbent Governor Doug Ducey is
leaving and there is an open seat the
Democratic nominee is Katie Hobbs the
Republican nominee is one of the most
aggressively weaponized from a
disinformation big lie standpoint
candidates Carrie Lake she is Trump
endorsed she is Trump loved right now
it pains me to say this Kerry lake is
winning by just under one point
and the last two polls that were done an
Insider Advantage poll and an ohpi poll
each has Lake ahead by three
Kerry lake is a lunatic
again it's sort of like if Herschel
Walker were to win if Kerry Lake wins it
is another serious humiliation for the
United States our Arizona viewers
you in Pennsylvania
you've got a lot on your shoulders here
we really have to do everything we can
to prevent Carrie Lake from winning we
then have in Ohio
uh JP Mandel right no JD Vance versus
Tim Ryan
Tim Ryan is not the best candidate his
debate performance was not
exactly beautiful
but JD Vance is a trump ass kisser
exactly the way that Tim Ryan described
him in the last debate and sadly JD
Vance is winning by just under one point
and the polling seems to be moving in
Vance's favor if you vote in Ohio this
is a big one
and then lastly in Georgia
uh uh we have oh I've got to do the
Herschel Walker one as well second to
last the state of Georgia uh it's
incumbent Republican Brian Kemp versus
Challenger Stacy Abrams Stacy Abrams is
extraordinary Kemp is horrible and Kemp
is winning by five okay so our Georgia
voters many many
extraordinarily important races for you
and let me just get the Walker Warnock
numbers up as well because those are so
important in the Walker Warnock race and
we will get to their debate a little bit
later Raphael Warnock is up by a hair
over three points but Herschel Walker is
gaining on him
so Georgia
um I and I know I didn't do Texas
Georgia Pennsylvania and Arizona
multiple important races I hope
everybody there is voting we'll get to
the debates later in the show the David
packman shows longest running sponsor is
blinkist the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils each of them
down into an explainer you can read or
listen to in 15 minutes blinkist also
condenses episodes of popular podcasts
into 15-minute explainers I've been
using blinkist for years to supplement
the books I read I love reading I I read
all the time but there's even more books
I don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcast casts between users I have a
joint blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below